we're good to go we're good to go okay
um again the slides are already up on my
website for this presentation
and so what i want to do is just
look at a few other bits and pieces in
the c groups interface
three pieces
release notification delegation and
thread mode which is something of an
innovation
or perhaps it's a dispute resolution
in sea groups version two
that will become a bit clearer
okay
all these features by the way in some
form were present in secrets version one
as well but the implementation or the
design is better in sea groups version
two
because
secrets version one one it was a mess
okay so what i mean by release
notification
the general idea here is you've got a
you've got a c group
you put some processes into the c group
but then eventually all those processes
leave the c group either they get moved
into different c groups
or they terminate and the c group
becomes empty
now in that circumstance we might want a
notification to tell us that the c group
has become empty and we can get such a
notification
this is what cgroup release notification
is about
and why might we be interested in
knowing that sort of thing
well
we might have a manager process that's
created the number of workers and put
them into a c group and when all those
workers finish their work and terminate
and the secret becomes empty then the
manager process knows the workers have
done their work
or we could want to do the thing that
system d does
probably many of you are familiar with
the idea that systemd has the facility
facility to respawn daemons that
accidentally terminate
system d is using this feature it puts a
process or puts a demon process into a c
group
and it monitors that c group to see if
it becomes empty and if it does become
empty then it knows the demon
prematurely terminated
and it restarts that demon
now how does this feature work in
secrets version two inside each c group
there is a file called c group dot
events and this is a file of keys and
corresponding values that have
state information about the c group at
the moment there's only two keys once
upon a time there was only one but
nowadays there are two
and
one of the keys is a key called
populated and it tells us
does this c group or any of its c
descendant c groups have member
processes
if the value in the file is one then
somewhere in this sub tree there is at
least one process
the file has if the key has the value
zero then
this c group and none of its descendants
have member processes
and then
the idea is that you can monitor these
files to find out the cgroup.events
files to find out when the keys change
and there's a couple of ways that you
can do the
monitoring of this of these files one is
you can use the i notify mechanism and
uh which is a sort of a generalized file
system notification mechanism i notified
lets you things like monitoring a
directory to find out was a new file
created in that directory was a file
modified in the directory was a
file renamed and so on so we can use i
notify for this job and if one of the
keys changes in particular if the
populated key changes then inertify
gives us a so-called
modify event back and then we can react
to that event by looking inside the file
to see did the populated key change
alternatively
we can open a file descriptor on one of
these files and monitor that file script
using
select poll or epoll
and if the content of the file changes
then what we get on the file descriptor
is either a
priority
notification if you're talking about
poll or epoll or what's called an in
select an exceptional notification
once we've got one of those
notifications then we just go and pass
the cgroup.events file to see what has
happened to the populated key and of
course it might not be the populated key
that has changed it could have been the
frozen key for example so when you
actually pass the file and check the
value of the key to find out has the
populated key changed
you can have one process that monitors
multiple c group dot events files
or different processes that monitor
different c group dot events files
the nice thing here is that this means
you can have a different process
monitoring different parts of the
c group
hierarchy the secret.events files and
different parts of the hierarchy so that
for instance one process might be
monitoring all the cgroup.events files
associated with a certain container
and another process might be monitoring
the sql.events files associated with a
different container and so on this was
functionality that was not possible in
secrets version one
we talked about the notifications being
delegated
per per container or per group of
processes
okay so let's try this out
give myself a super user shell of course
and i'll make a
child c group
now if i look inside that child c group
in fact i'm going to do this a little
bit differently
uh
now i'm going to remind myself for some
syntax here
because i often get this wrong
well i'll do the simple thing first
let's just cat
and i'm in the wrong place of course
right now
that's cat
c group events
we see certain values there for the keys
there is no process inside the c group
at the moment
now
let's
create a process
and okay now before i do that
i'm going to use
i notify weight
i notify weight is a command line
interface to the inodify mechanism
i'm going to say i know while i notify
white i have to remind myself for the
options there i want to say yes q dash e
modify
and i want to do this repeatedly
and i'm going to say this on
i want to monitor this see events file
and
whenever i get a notification what
happens the the form of inaudib
there is a notification event so every
time there's a modify event on that file
and let's go around and loop calling i
notify wait again and again the dash
queue just says be quiet
don't actually give me any printed
information just return when there is a
notification event
and
whenever i do get that notification
event i'm just going to say let's
display the populated key
in that cgroup.events file
and then i'm done
no i'm not what did i do wrong
oh
now okay good now i'm done
so
now i'm going to create a
sleep process
and then i'm going to move that sleep
process into the c group
now when i did that
that generated an event because the
populated key changed
and of course the
loop down below
when the notification occurred
my
my loop gripped for the key
inside the secret.events file and we
just changed the value 1.
now let's create another sleep process
and put its pid in there as well
oh that's a bit of a coincidence exactly
100 apart
okay
that didn't generate a notification by
the way okay because the populated key
is a boolean key it's telling us that
there is at least one process in the
hierarchy
now
suppose i now say kill the first process
three four eight
one eight five
again there's no notification the value
of that
key
of that key in that file just
cut that file
the value of the key
is still one
but if i kill the other sleep process
now i get a notification
okay because in that subtree now there
are no more
live processes
so this is this idea of release
notification
i think i've covered most of this
yeah
okay so that's release notification then
uh someone overhead a question that i
said the answer is delegation i was yes
it was yes
everything i've been doing so far i did
as super user
of course that's not so nice if we're
thinking about the notion of
unprivileged containers containers run
by unplugged users because
we don't want to have we don't want to
have the container need to be privileged
in order to use c groups
so
this is what delegation is about passing
ownership of some sub-hierarchy
in the version 2 hierarchy to some less
privileged user
user id 1000 for
example need a bit of terminology
delegator and delegatee what i mean by
the delegator is the privileged user
probably super user who owns the parent
c group
and then the delegatee is the
unprivileged
to which we're going to pass ownership
of some sub-tree underneath that
parentheses group
now
the way that you do delegation is
just make the
child c group
writable by the
by the delegatee
the the usual way of doing that is
to change the ownership of the directory
and then the directory is you know
writable by the unprivileged user
so you change the ownership of the
directory
that is going to be the root of your new
delegated subtree
and you have to change the ownership
some files inside that directory as well
the cgroup.prox file so that the
delegatee can write pids into that
seagroup.prox file
and also the subtree control file
because then the delegate t
can
enable controllers inside the delegate
inside the delegated tree
you might also need to change the
ownership of a few other files and the
set of files whose ownership you need to
change has evolved over time
there's been a few new files that have
been added over time
[Music]
that
they also need to be delegated and then
your question becomes well i'm using a
certain kernel version
on that kernel version when i do
delegation which files need to be
changed which files need to have their
own ship changed
nowadays the kernel has a little
interface for allowing you to discover
that information there's a file called
or the pseudo file syskernal c group
delegate and that file just lists the
names of files that you need to change
the ownership for during the delegation
stamp
and so you see there cgroup.prox and
cgroup.subtree control but there's a
couple other files that might be present
in the c group directory and if they are
you also need to change their ownership
as well
there are some files in the directory
though whose ownership you don't want to
change and these are the resource
controller interface files things like
pids.net and cpu.max because they are
being used from the level above
to limit resources that come into this c
group and the delegate even less
privileged user shouldn't be able to
change the limits that are coming in
from outside the c group so those files
should still remain
owned by the delegate t
so in terms of a picture this is what
the delegation step looks like
we've got
the parent c group that's owned by the
delegator presumably super user
then
a child c group that we're going to
delegate to the delegatee so we change
the ownership of that
that directory to being the delegatee
and then within that directory we change
the ownership of the other files that
are shown here in blue
the ownership of these other files also
to be
the delegate
but
the other files
inside that cgroup the resource
controller interface files they remain
owned by the delegator
because they are what are being used to
control from outside
in terms of resources that come into
this c group
now once we've done the delegation step
the delegate t
the less privileged user can then create
child c groups
those child secrets will inherit their
ownership from the parent c group so
that also be owned by the delegate t
and all of the files including the
resource controller interface files
inside those child c groups
will be owned by the delegate t
so the delegate can freely modify
resource limits in the
lower level c groups
okay
now
there are
there's a
set of rules which are called the
delegation containment rules and the
idea of the delegation containment rules
is that the delegatee
is allowed to move processes around
within the delegated subtree
but can't do things like moving a
process from the outside of the
hierarchy into the delegated sub tree or
vice versa
and the rules go like this that the
writing pro the the delete the writing
process that which is presumably owned
by the delegatee
in order to move a process from a source
c group to a target c group two rules
the writing process needs to have right
permission on the cgroup.prox file in
the target c group and write permission
on the c group dot prox file in the
common ancestor of the source c group
and the target c group
now the effect of those rules
is that
for example
the presumption here uh well there's
various c groups here that are owned by
different user ids the root c group for
example owned by uid 0 but then there
are other c groups that are owned by
other users they've been delegated
and
the delegation containment rules would
let us do things like saying we could
move a
user id 1000 could move a process from c
group m
to c group in
the reason is uid 1000 has write
permission on the c group.props file in
the target c group in
and also has write permission on the c
group.prox file in
the common ancestor which is b
likewise
uid 1000 could move a process from c
group m
to c group x
we need to have right permission on the
target c group which is x and when you
have right permission on the c group dot
proximal in the common ancestor the
common ancestor of m and x is x
on the other hand
user id 1000 couldn't move a process
from c group x
to c group y
okay because
doesn't have right permission on the
seagroup.prox file in the common
ancestor
and you know
if you think about unprivileged
containers owned by the same user that
feels good because you wouldn't want to
you know
a user could set up two different
containers and then move a process from
one container to the other that would
that would be icky
okay
so
let's try some things out
maybe i'll just better start again here
alrighty so
the top window here i'm a privileged
user
and
just change my shell prompt something
less noisy
i'm going to create a
child c group
i'll call it d group for delegated group
now if i do an ls-ld
on
that directory okay it's owned by super
user
but i want to delegate that
directory
to an unprevious user okay down below i
am user id 1000 user mtk
so
to do the delegation step all i do as
the delegator
is say change the ownership
of
that directory
to unprevious user
and associated group
on
the group
but also
on some files inside the group c dot
procs
and
c group dot subtree control
those are the only files i i happen to
know this
what have i done oh yeah hey that's
interesting isn't it
okay let's let's undo that
now let's try and do that
there
i happen to know that those are the only
files in that directory that need have i
still messed up
oh yeah thank you
they're all just here to help me debug
um
so
i happen to know that those are the only
files inside that directory that need to
be delegated
there is no file called secret.threads
in that directory and there is no no
no
files associated with the memory
controller either
now i can then do
a bit of verification
where i say
ls dash
l
dn
long listing
in fact we don't need the end
okay so those files have been changed to
unprovisional
me
and i've got right permission on those
files
now
what that means and i'll just down in
the shell below
i'll just step
into that directory
what that means is that as i'm
privileged user i could now create child
c groups underneath that delegated c
root so if i say make the
group 1
group
and then i do an ls ld on those
two directories okay they're owned by me
and if i look at the files inside one of
those directories
all the files are owned by the
unprivileged user
so this means that as the unproven user
i could do things like
once controllers are enabled i could
start setting limits inside those child
c groups
now
let's try
to put
this shell
into that
um the delegated group so i'll say
echo dollar dollar into
[Music]
the
oh i'm indeed i'm in the yes i'm in that
group already yes
so
pwd echo
dollar dollar into c group dot
procs
failed why is that
at a guess
i don't have right permission in the
common ancestor and you're quite right
there's one more piece that you need to
add there i think where does that shell
live at the moment at a guess
which c group
yeah it's probably in the root c group
let's let's go and check that
camp smash proc slash dollar dollar
slash
c group
oh okay no it's not in the root secrets
and something that was created by system
d of course but the point is the common
ancestor is the root c group
and i don't have right permission on the
c group dot prox file in in the root c
group in the common ancestor
okay so to get the very first process
into the delegated c group
that actually needs to be done by the
delegator the privileged user
so let's from
let's find out the pid of that shell
okay that's that pid so then i could say
here echo that pid three three four
eight
eight five five zero
into
d group
c group dot products
and
then if i now grab
also cat proc dollar c group okay the
only the secret membership has changed
now
i could
from the shell because the shell is
owned by use radio 1000 i could now
create a process
if i look at the that sleep process that
i've just created if i look at its c
group membership
it's in the same c group as its parent
because that's how it happens by default
and what i could now do as the unproven
user is say
echo
that pid into
one of the
child c group c group dot prox files
and that works i now again cat
the prop f secret file i see the
membership has changed
and i could
move it around a bit more
moved into other c group the other child
c group
and again we see the path name has
changed what i couldn't do
is
something like
trying to echo that pid into ccfs
c group c group dot prox try and move it
into the root c group
this is delegation containment in action
i think i've covered all of that
yeah that's that
okay
this is going to be a short session but
that means i can do a better demos demo
thread mode
okay
so
well perhaps though before i talk about
thread are there any questions so far
because we have got a bit of time in
hand
or you can think of questions at the end
yes please
are you talking about the rules
yeah
next one yes
ah
yes
yeah if you try to move from k to m
you're allowed to as user id 1000
yeah
i i know if it feels a bit strange
because you've moved over a c group that
was owned by a different user but
according to the rules that's allowed
and perhaps if you'd like to think of it
you know from the point of view of you
know the the the tree root of x might be
associated with a container owned by
user id 1000 and user id 1000 is sort of
god in that container so you can do that
sort of thing
but yeah it is it does feel a bit
strange and this this is a slightly
unusual setup for you but it's it's it's
a theoretically possible setup
uh
oh so what was i thought you said did
you say jada x
or k to m
k to m yes that's fine but yes that's
that's you couldn't move
um that's true according to the
delegation containment rules you
couldn't move a process from
j to k
okay it is a weird situation
could you move from jay to
i and i think according to the
delegation containment rules the answer
is yes
yes
it's a weird setup
um but i'm pretty sure the answer is yes
um i can't see any reason why not i've
never done that particular experiment
but yeah
um
yeah but i'm sure the answer is yes
okay thread mode
when cigarettes version 2 was initially
um
designed there was a one of the design
decisions was that the
the granularity for c group membership
will be at the process level in other
words all the threads in a
multi-threaded process must be in the
same c group
version one
had allowed something different with
version one you could have a
multi-threaded process where
some threads were in one c group another
threads were in a different c group
and for some controllers this made sense
in particular for the cpu controller
people had use cases where you'd have a
multi-threaded process where you wanted
some threads that were subject to one
cpu limit but other threads that should
be subjected to a different cpu limit
the reason that that wasn't that idea
was not initially implemented in secrets
version 2 is
for some other controllers this made no
sense
the the most striking example is the
memory controller suppose you had a
multi-threaded process
where you try to put some threads in one
memory c group with a certain limit and
other threads in a different
c group with different memory limits
given that threads share in address
space what could that situation possibly
mean
so
when secrets version 2 was
first implemented the design decision
was
we won't have that sort of messiness
they'll just be thread level granularity
for sorry process level granularity for
for a c group membership
but there were these use cases in
version one especially to do with the
cpu controller and this led to
a long running
skirmish
between two different groups of kernel
developers and the the i said that
secrets version two was released in um
the skirmish had already been going on
for a year
and when secrets version 2 was released
there was no cpu controller
i
i don't know what the sea group version
2 maintainers hoped perhaps they hope
the problem would just go away and we'd
get a cpu controller according to our
idea
but the
s the kernel scheduler maintainers had
other ideas so on the one hand with the
secret version two maintainers that said
the level of
uh for secret membership the granularity
for secret membership will be the
process level all threads must be in the
same c group
on the other hand you had the colonel
scheduler maintainers who said if you
want to merge a cpu controller into our
scheduler
you're going to satisfy that use case
that was possible in
secrets version 1 where you could have
different threads in different cpuc
groups
one of the things that might not have
helped here too much is that one of the
colonel scheduler maintainers
hates secrets
wishes they'd never appeared
anyway eventually there was a compromise
found and this compromise was something
called thread mode
and thread mode allows a limited form of
thread level granularity for certain
controllers for the certain controllers
where it makes sense
and
how does this work well now c groups
have different types we talk about
domain c groups and threaded c groups
a domain c group is one
which has the original rule
a process in one in a domain c group all
the threads must be in the same c group
this was the original version two
default
but what you can also do within this
overall
version to hierarchy is create what are
called threaded subtrees and in a
threaded sub tree and you can have
several different threaded subtrees in a
threaded subtree you can have
the threads of a process split across
different c groups
there's one rule which is that all the
threads in a pr in that process must be
in the same threaded sub-tree there can
be many threaded sub-trees
but all the threads of any particular
multi-threaded process must be in the
same threaded sub-tree
so there is now thread level granularity
in version two but it's more restricted
than version one
and so we've got the idea like this here
i've got a
version two hierarchy where there is one
threaded
subtree
and there's a few threaded c groups
inside that subtree and the idea is that
you'd have a multi-threaded process that
where the threads were split across the
c groups inside that threaded subtree
okay now
a change that happened at the same time
is now
controllers were split into two types
so-called threaded controllers and
domain controllers and the idea of the
threaded controllers these are the
controllers that support
that sensibly support the idea of thread
level granularity for secret membership
where it's meaningful to split threads
apart for the purposes of doing resource
management the other controllers which
is most of them are the so-called domain
controllers and they only understand
process granularity for c group
membership
so these threaded controls they
understand threaded sub trees what i
mean by they they understand threaded
subtrees is
that
going back to that
uh
tree sorry i'll i'll do the drawing here
on the screen that's a bad idea that
going back to this picture here for the
threaded controllers
controller interface files things like
cpu.max
will appear in those child c groups
on the other hand for the domain
controllers the controller interface
files won't appear because domain
controllers don't understand threaded
subtrees
for a domain controller it looks
like
all the all the the processes reside in
the root of the tree because domain
controllers
they can't have their interface files
enabled at lower levels in the tree so
the lowest level that a domain
controller can do management is the root
of the threaded subtree
okay
[Music]
now in order to do the um
the management here of these c group
these threaded c groups there's a couple
of new files that appear there's now a
file called cgroup.threads
if you write a thread id into that file
that'll move a single thread into that c
group
and this is the way that you split the
threads of a multi-threaded process into
different
c groups in the threaded sub tree by
using this file
and then there's another file
cgroup.type
and what this file does is
expose or allow you to modify the type
of a c group
c groups to begin with they have type
domain domain c group only supports
process level granularity for c group
membership but there are other types
there's a type called threaded and this
means this is a c group in one of these
threaded sub trees
there are other strings that can appear
in this file domain threaded this means
this is one of these
uh this is a c group that is at the root
of a threaded sub tree it's sort of that
crossover point going back here it's at
that
crossover point between the domain outer
world and the threaded subtree
underneath
and
there's one more
c group type that i really don't want to
get into it's slightly confusing
called domain invalid maybe it's not so
much it's confusing i just don't buy the
rationale for its existence
there is a rationale but it's
questionable i would say
this domain and valid state this is a c
group that is
invalid
basically it's a temporary state on the
way to creating a threaded subtree
what you have ultimately with one of
these domain and valid secrets is turn
it into a threaded c group
there are a couple of different ways for
creating these threaded subtrees and i
don't have slides here to show you but
i'll just do the demonstration you can
find the details in in the manual page
there are quite a few rules about doing
this
um and again it's a bit more than i have
space to cover but i'll just do some
demonstrations
and yes we're after that we're done
now um what i'm going to do is make a
little bit of sub hierarchy and then
make a threaded subtree
so i'll make a director under here a in
fact i'll say magda dash p
so a
b
c
d
and maybe
c
and
sorry c and
e
and maybe
a slash x slash y
slash said
i think that's enough
now
one way of making a threaded subtree is
i write the string threaded
into
a cgroup.typefile
so i'm going to write that
string
into the secret dot type file of
the c group c
now
what this does
is make that let's cap that file just to
verify the change and i i should have
cut that file beforehand but if i i can
just cat another file just to
demonstrate the default
that was not the file i meant to cat
let's look at the
c group a
that's the default type for c groups now
i made
c
threaded
and
okay
what that did was cause the parent of c
to become domain threaded the slightly
weird way to go but it's how it works
this caused the parent c secret become
domain threaded and all the other
descendants of the parentsy group became
invalid
so if i then said cat a slash b slash d
slash c group dot
us
a slash b slash d
c group
why am i getting this wrong
oh yes
a slash b slash d slash c group dot type
the other descendants underneath b
became domain and valid
now if you're trying to do these
experiments you quickly start to go a
little bit
mad cutting files
trying to visualize things and it's not
that much fun
so you want a little go program that i
prepared earlier
and
so i can now say go run
oops of course i should have said mtk
few v2c groups
and
i want to view the hierarchy
go
a slash b
and this program gives me a little
visualization because that's much easier
than cutting files all over the place
and so what we can see is that
c
has type threaded the parent has type
domain threaded and the other
descendants of the parent have become
invalid
if i'd
done the viewing instead of c group
a okay a has typed main
under b has domain threaded now the next
thing i would do to create a threaded
subtree is i've got to channel all those
domain and valid c groups into threaded
c groups and so i say echo
threaded
into a slash b
c slash
d slash c group dot type
and the same thing in the c group e
and then if i re-visualize
now i've got a fully threaded subtree
what i could now do
is
put a process inside that tree
now let's make a
a process
what this post program does is create
one thread for each command line
argument and each of the threads tries
to burn some cpu time
so and
three threads is enough
okay
each of those three threads is getting a
hundred percent of cpu time because of
course i've got a lot of cpus
and
what i could then do is move
that
process
into the threaded subtree and the way
that i do that is i say echo
the pid which is three five
one one six two
into
a slash b slash
c
c group
dot procs
now
if i cap that file
something slightly odd happens
i get an error
the reason is that from the perspective
of the threaded sub-tree the process is
considered to be a member of the root of
the threaded sub-tree in other words
it's considered to be a member of
a slash b
which was the root of the threaded
subtree
so
processes are always considered to be
members of the root of a threaded sub
tree but individual threads can be
members of various c groups within the
threaded subtree so for instance if i
said cat a slash b slash
c
c group dot threads
there's all the thread ids they are in
that descendancy group
again you go a little bit mad trying to
cat everything here and again
my little go program just makes life a
little bit easier by showing me where
the pids are and where the thread ids
are all the program there is doing there
is inspecting
cgroup.proc files and secret.threads
files and displaying the information
now what i could then do is
things like this where i say echo
let's say
twenty thousand
into a slash b
c slash d
slash
cp oh hang on a little problem there i
was going to enable
cpu limits
but of course what i haven't done is
enable the cpu controller all the way
down at the very end the various c
groups so let's just quickly do a little
bit of
first of all enable cpu
in the
subtree control file at the root c group
then in
a
and
b
c
i really like my little go program
because it gives me visualizations all
these things which would otherwise i
would go crazy because it's telling me
the cpu control is enabled now in those
c groups
so then i want to do things like saying
echo
some quota and period
into
a slash b slash c
d slash
cpu
dot max
just by the way little test
i enabled the cpu controller in a and b
and c
but i set a limit in d why didn't i need
to enable the controller in d
no
button
it's always the level above that it's
controlling the next level down
if i want to do control and d i have to
enable the controller at the level above
okay i've set a certain cpu limit there
and let's set one an e as well
and then i can start moving threads into
these c groups so i could then say echo
say
three five
one one six two into a slash b slash c
slash d slash
c group dot threads
and of course i meant to use a different
number here
let's make the limit in e 20 percent
and what you can see down below by the
way if i just freeze the output there
for a moment you can see there that
this thread is only getting 50 of the
cpu now
50 of us cpu
and i've set a different limit in c
group e so let's move a different thread
in there
[Music]
6 3
and
again you can see there it's converging
on a lower value now
oh i measured wrong c group didn't i i
mean to move it into e
okay
okay we're at steady state there now you
can see that
this thread is getting 20 percent
this thread is getting 50 of a cpu the
other thread is getting 100 of a cpu
because it's it's not limited by
anything at the moment
okay now if i put two threads into the
same c group let's put the third thread
also into c group e
so i put
just resume that output if i put
three one
three five one six six four
into e as well
it a moment
it takes going to take me you know 10
seconds or so for it to stabilize now
okay what you can see that the two
threads that are in c group e are
sharing the 20 percent
that is available to that c group and so
they're each getting 10 of the cpu
okay that is essentially thread mode
i think i'm done and there's a few
minutes left in case there are some
questions
martin
okay so it's a nice question the pids
controller is misnamed
the pids controller you know
it's not limiting pids it's limiting
tasks it's limiting threads individual
threads count against the limit so if
you took a multithreaded process and put
some threads in one pid c group and
other threads in another pidc group then
it would limit those the the ability of
each of those threads to create further
threads or further processes
yeah
that's why it's a threaded controller
despite the name
other questions
ah yes i'm jim
there is a story um
there is look i i am just the messenger
okay
the
to me the question is why do we need the
main invalid no mode at all why couldn't
you just write domain threaded into a
certain c group and that makes
everything underneath threaded
that would be so much simpler wouldn't
it
yeah
but it's not the world we have and this
is because at a
a certain point there was a discussion
that there might be possibility for
something called mixed mode where you
might have a threaded subtree but then
underneath there might be some domain
subtree now what this could mean was
never fully elaborated
but then the decision was made well
let's allow for this in the future we
don't know quite what it's going to look
like but we're going to allow for it and
what this means that you know we don't
necessarily want to make the the
decision up front what should be the
type of one of these c groups underneath
the thread sub tree i don't buy it
because you know if we need to do that
thing differently then perhaps we could
have had a world we just wrote domain
threaded into a c group dot type file
and it did you know made everything
threaded underneath and if you need to
do something else different in the
future
you write some different string into
these files but it's what we have
that's right
please question
no so underneath the domain threaded c
group the only kinds of c groups you'll
find are either threaded or domain
yeah so if you write threaded into ac
file that makes the parent domain
threaded and everything underneath that
domain thread of ancestor
domain and value everything else domain
and valid
it's it's weird but it's the way it
works
no the only string you can write to
these files is the string threaded
in other words the only explicit
transition that you can make
is
to convert a c group to type threaded
now there are implicit transitions that
can happen though and i'll just quickly
illustrate that
that
let's do that visualization again
the c group there x has type domain
and so what if i make
the type of
y
threaded so i'll say echo
threaded into a slash x slash y
slash c group dot
type
and visualize
parents become domain threaded
the sibling has become domain invalid
but what if i do this
r m der
a slash x slash
y
now the reason that x is threaded the
main thread i should say is because it
has a threaded child what if i remove
that threaded child
i can do it
and then
what happened
to
x it reverted to type domain and its
child reverted to type domain as well
so there are these kinds of implicit
transitions that can happen if the
ancestor is no longer forced to being
domain threaded
there is another way that you can create
a threaded sub tree but i i won't try
and talk about that here but this but
basically
there's two ways you can create a
threaded subtree but if the the thing
that triggers the creation of the
threaded sub tree is undone
then the ancestor the the domain
threaded root reverts to being type
domain
in this scenario yes but in the other
scenario it looks a little bit different
but even so if you reverse the steps
then the the the conversion to domain
thread is undone
joking
yes
sorry if you have the main thread
history group could you
ah
yes you could
so let's let's let's say make so um
well here's our visualization at the
moment we've got a and x and z let's
make
z threaded
into
a slash ink slash
z slash c group dot type
now that of course turned
x into domain threaded now what if we
then wrote threaded
into
a slash x that's what you're talking
about isn't it
[Music]
now i'm confused
oh no i think that's because of
something else that's going on which is
i've got the main controllers enabled at
certain levels above
yeah so that you can actually do this
sort of thing and if i didn't have other
domain controllers enabled because there
are some rules that i haven't talked
about um but you can do that sort of
thing where you write threaded into a
secret that is currently remain threaded
and that causes the parent to become a
domain threaded and that domain threaded
child becomes threaded now
and the other descents become domain
invalid
uh no if a c group if a sibling is
already threaded that stays threaded
[Music]
i know i think it should become threaded
as well yeah and there's something else
let's do with the controllers i think
i'd have to look more closely i've
broken another rule that i haven't
explained
yes please
oh that's that's the rule i've broken
thank you i've just realized it
um
that you
if i do the visualization thank you for
that question
the rule that i've broken is you can't
turn a particular node into domain
threaded if there are descendant c
groups that have member processes
already
and i was trying to turn a into the main
threaded but already underneath a there
is c group b
that has a member process that's the
rule i broke
um i wasn't thinking quite quickly
enough
um but you know to
to finally do your question your iq in a
different way let's just say make the
p slash q slash r
oh you make dash p
and then
do the visualization on p
okay and then if i make
echo
threaded
into p slash q slash r
slash
c group dot type
do the visualization the parents become
remain threaded but then if i
do that
on q
and visualize again
let's turn the
bit yeah
other questions
i think we're about at about time
okay thank you for your time
[Applause]